finalmente il momento della giornata che
preferisco cosa guardo stasera allora
devo finire questa iniziare quella hanno
appena messo tutte le stagioni sex and
the city quindi potrei anche rivedermi
quello però c'è questa qui che nuova
devo vederla e poi c'è poi c'è questa e
poi c'è chi però lo fanno apposta cioè
non basta una vita per vederle tutte a 1
fidati che questa serie la vita cioè
veramente stupendo il titolo devi dirgli
guardarla però ti ho detto che non mi
piace in una serie tv non le guardo ma
no ma no
anch'io la pensavo così di quelle prima
ma una volta che avevi questa col
proprio chi prende perché ti fa entrò in
un'altra dimensione e tu sei inglobata
nella serie se vuoi lo guardi l'episodio
ma no no allora facciamo faccio qui tu
ne guardi 3 barra 4 ti giuro che se non
ti piace non ti prendi t o forse no
ho appena preso tre caffè sosteranno mi
addormento definire assolutamente la
serie è arrivato io non ci credo che sia
piaciuta ciò è impossibile che sarei
visto ti dico che non mi è piaciuto a
marino mi ha più amante non è mai visto
un altra serie come si chiama game of
thrones
ora questi si chiama troyes padre io la
stessa cambio solo inglese italiano il
nome allora dei minori dei personaggi
scelti lannister veneris targaryen poi
c'è johnson dargli quella io sono
scioccata ci è piaciuta tutto il mondo
successo internazionale e a lui non
piace amo sta iniziando la tua serie
preferita
ti faccio a sapere se mi piace ciao ciao
by admin it later ma tu stai scherzando
fa schifo parte che non ci ho capito
nulla tutto il discorso iniziale che lei
è figlia dello stregone ma è anche
parente con questo discorso è manna ma
amo ma cosa centra cinque minuti bastano
per capire tutta la serie non poteva
andare avanti piu di cosi c'e veramente
stato uno sforzo immenso cinque minuti
vista serie in anno devo dirti una cosa
chi mi sai ieri connery sta anche se a
dormire sti ecco io non riuscivo a
prendere sonno
ho guardato qualche episodio di cosa
della nostra serie preferita se quanti
ne guardate due bar a 9 no no no nel 2o
né guardati no perché diverso
le guardie 11 finito la stagione senza
di me come potuto è una merda però ne
migliora vite mentre visitava ho fatto
un patto di fatto per questa cavolo di
fare il punto di doversi ti giuro che la
ricordo volentieri
basta è finita ciao
tranquilla marina non è successo niente
è solo finita la tua serie preferita ma
lo sapevi che sarebbe arrivato questo
momento no
però magari domani ne litio un'altra e
sarà altrettanto bella e ti prenderà
inizierà ad affezionarti a personaggi e
le loro storie è successo assolutamente
niente è solo una serie nuovo non puoi
capire ho iniziato una serie di cui
parlavi e sono presissima cioè veramente
pazzesca
io l'ho finito guerre smi spoiler ogni
volta risponde questa volta per favore
non me la rovinare perché mi sta
piacendo un saggio lavoro non ti sposero
viene giura ecco però stabiliti deluderò
come mi deluderà allora io ti voglio
ascoltare perché mi sta piacendo sono
sicura che non mi deluderà quindi tutto
è fatto così strano diverso genoma non
ti preoccupare non ti sposero niente non
si spogliò niente però secondo me a far
morire protagonista a metà stagione e mi
sembra una cosa troppo too much too much
and no non potete lasciarvi così sul più
bello cavoni come faccio
guardiamole un'altra six slate o finita
pro finita e non sarà più bella che gli
abbiamo visto attivo su un set tenuta la
scuola
[Musica]